welcome back to Las Vegas now I wish you
guys could smell this it not only looks
delicious but smells so good great funds
Bakery is celebrating 40 years in Las
Vegas and they are all about family and
delicious treats of course and joining
us today from great buns Bakery we have
Tony and Deborah thank you so much for
being here thank you for having us I am
distracted I don't even know where to
start but let's talk a little bit about
it you guys have such a rich deep
history here in Las Vegas tell us a
little bit about grape buns we do so
grapevine's Bakery my our great
grandfather came over from Italy with
our grandmother and he was a baker by
trade so he started a bakery in Buffalo
New York and my uncle worked there as a
young boy seven eight years old and then
got my my great uncle and my uncle came
in and they had Royal rolls back in
Buffalo they decided to retire and my
great uncle decided to move to Las Vegas
called my uncle and said you need to
come out and we're gonna do this all
over again get out of retirement so we
came out to Las Vegas in 1982. WoW
Charleston 1000 square feet and now
we're over on our Tropicana location for
since 1988. so that is amazing so been
here ever since and I like I said I'm
distracted I keep looking at everything
so when people come into your shop tell
us some of the stuff that they can get
what do we have in front of us well
we're pretty diverse compared to the
bakery that we had in Buffalo we were a
McDonald's Bakery back then okay only
had a couple of options but here we have
everything from our slice breads to our
rolls hot dog buns some focaccias
hamburger buns um our ciabatta Italian
bread we have a lot of breakfast items
that we sell to wholesale and Retail
customers we all have our favorites well
don't miss the white chocolate raspberry
that is definitely a go-to for you you
said raspberry is your favorite but you
really can't go wrong with any of it and
you mentioned breakfast so you guys set
aside a cinnamon roll here for me
cinnamon rolls are my absolute favorite
I'm gonna take a bite and try it but
tell us a little bit about how you're
celebrating 40 years you just had a
special event that was yesterday right
we did we did we were very fortunate we
had mayor Goodman out we did a ribbon
cutting with the chamber we had a lot of
support from vendors and customers and
everything like that it was a it was a
great day in addition to that today we
did a celebration for our employees so
we're trying to extend this as opposed
to just a anniversary day and
anniversary week well it's a huge
milestone you guys congratulations and I
know anyone watching at home or even in
our studio you know wants to have these
in their home so you guys do catering a
little bit of everything right a little
bit of everything yes well happy 40
years this is amazing I'm just going to
be eating this the rest of the day I'm
going to be on a sugar high but in a
great way you guys Happy 40 years thanks
for being here be sure to go check out
great buns Bakery Kendall I'll send